اذهب الان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت القياده العسكريه
الجنوبيه في اوكرانيا اسقاط الثلاثين
مسيره فوق مقاطعات اوديسا
الليله الماضيه في هجوم روسي واسع بعشرات
الطائرات المسيره على المناطق ان الوضع
الميداني في جنوب البلاد متوتر وان القتال
مستمر ضد ما سمتها المدفعيه المعاديه
واضحك اوضحت ان القوات الروسيه مستمره في
استخدام الطيران التكتيكي بنشاط جانبه قال
الجيش الاوكرانيين الهجمات الروسيه
استهدفت ايضا عشرات البلدات جنوبيه البلاد
في الساعه 24 الاخيره
اما فيزا جنوب شرق اوكرانيا فقد هزت اربعه
انفجارات المدينه اثر تعرضها لقصف صاروخي
الروسي وقالت الاداره العسكريه في الاقليم
من خمسه اشخاص اصيبوا بسبب ذلك وفد مراسل
الجزيره بسماع صافرات الانذار محذره من
هجوم صاروخي قد تعرض له المدينه وشهدت
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد لاحقا من اكثر من
مكان في المدينه
الاداره العسكريه في مقاطعه دينيبرو قالت
من جانبها ان مدينه
الماضيه لقصف روسيا بالمدفعيه الثقيله
ولكن دون تسجيل خسائر بشريه وضفت الاداره
انها تجري تمشيطا للمنطقه للوقوف على ما
احدثه القصف من اضرار محتمله في البنيه
التحتيه مدينه
تقع على ضفه نهر دنيبر المقابله لمحطه
النوويه والتي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
وكانت تاجهتنا دوليه عده حضرت مرارا من
عواقب القتال الدائر في محيط المحطه
النوويه
قالت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
اقليم خيرسون ان منشات تعليميه تضررت
نتيجه قصف الروسي على خير وذكرت الاداره
ان القصف الحق اضرارا في احدى المؤسسات
التعليميه ومباني المدرستين العليا
والابتدائيه بالمدينه سنتعرضت قريه
في اقليم خيرسون للقصف باربع قذائف مدفعيه
من قبل الجيش الروسي ما اوقع اضرارا ماديه
في منشاه تجاريه وطبيبيه وزراعيه
في المقابل قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
دفاعاتها تصدت لهجوم اوكراني بتسعه صواريخ
من نوع اورجان في اجواء مقاطعه بيل جروندل
قريبه من الحدود الاوكرانيه الوزاره اضافت
ان منظومات الدفاع الجوي تصدت للصواريخ
الاوكرانيه ودمرتها بالكامل على حد وصفها
كما نشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صورا قالت
انها لغارات شنتها
للجيش الاوكراني في مقاطعه دونا ذكر
تفاصيل بشان المواقع المستهدفه او الخسائر
التي تسببت فيها الغارات
والان ينضم الينا من زفروجيا مراسلنا
الياس كرام التركيز كبير على وهو مستمر
منذ فتره ولكن ضعنا في صوره اخر ما يجري
فيها
عسكريه مغلقه حيث اننا منعنا ايضا من
التصوير في المنطقه القريبه من حيث سقط
احد الصواريخ في بلده مدفيفكا قربه محطه
للقطارات لكن من الواضح بان الاستهدافات
كانت استهدافات
باتجاه مواقع
للبناء التحتيه ومصانع الصلب التي تشتهر
فيها هذه المدينه هنالك مصانع للحديد
بكثره في المنطقه الشماليه للمدينه التي
طالها هذا القصف وايضا المطار المدني
الموجود في منطقه زبروجيا والتابع للمدينه
الذي بطبيعه الحال هو مغلق منذ بدايه هذا
الحرب لكن كما يبدو ايضا يستخدم للاغراض
العسكريه وبالتالي يتحول ايضا لاهداف
بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه التي تقصف هذه
المواقع هنا في بلده مدفيدكا هذا الصاروخ
الذي سقط على السكه الحديديه في المنطقه
اوقع اضرارا في بعض المباني السكنيه
القريبه من هذا الخط السريع
وبحسب الاداره العسكريه اوقع على الاقل 5
جرحه في صفوف المدنيين الاوكرانيين في هذه
البلدان نشير هنا الى ان مدينه زبروج
يتحولت عمليا الى مدينه هامه في اطار
العمليه العسكريه التي تخوضها القوات
الاوكرانيه في هذا المحور جنوبا ذلك انها
هي المدينه المركزيه التي توفر كل
الاحتياجات اللوجستيه للقوات الاوكرانيه
المتوغله ضمن هذا الهجوم الذي يراوح مكانه
حقيقه منذ نحو شهر في محور الرابوتين
وبرفيفيه وايضا القوات العسكريه الروسيه
كما كنت تشير في الايام الماضيه بدات توجه
ضرباتها الى الخطوط الخلفيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه المتوغله في هذا المحور عند
اوريخوف وماليا وغيرها من البلدات
اوكرانيه التي تحولت الى بمثابه مواقع
للخطوط الخلفيه الاوكرانيه وهذا الهجوم
الصاروخي بالصواريخ الباليستيه الدقيقه
المركزه على هذه المنشات التي يبدو انها
كانت تستهدف كما اشرت المنشات الصناعيه
والاستراتيجيه بالمدينه تاتي ايضا في اطار
الرد على العمليه العسكريه المتواصله في
هذه المنطقه ونحن نرى دائما هذه الامدادات
العسكريه المتواصله التي يدفع فيها الجيش
الاوكراني الى المنطقه الجنوبيه هذا
الراتل العسكري الذي يتوجه كما يبدو الى
مناطق القتال كهذه الابطال العسكريه نراها
دائما في خدمها هذا مشهد
اشكرك جزيلا الياس كرام على كل هذه
المعلومات